uh let's go to your voicemails now we
have a voicemail number that number is
219
to david p here's a really funny
voicemail about a pen
uh about a fly landing on mike pence's
head during the debate take a look
bro pence is such garbage
a literal fly just landed on this guy's
head
he is such trash that literally flies
are landing on his head what's the
opposite of when
bernie gets a bird to land on is on his
little podium
it's when a fly lands on pence's trash
ass head
goodbye pants bye bye
yeah a lot of people reacting to the fly
that that uh took hold of
mike pence's hair and seemed to get sort
of caught up in his hair gel
um i i read a lot of interesting things
about how i i'm as you know i'm not
religious and i don't know if this is
old testament or new testament stuff or
whatnot but
i guess a fly landing on your head is
considered to be a very ominous sign
at least in some biblical teaching and a
bunch of people wrote to me
wrote wrote to me about that it doesn't
resonate with me but with pence being
such a religious guy
it is pretty damn funny we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
update
the uh biden harris student debt plan
i think this is important and i want to
go over it we will also talk about
24 super habitable planets
that have conditions that are better for
human life
than earth better and we will also talk
about the lgbt takeover of the proud
boys hashtag
on the internet it is absolutely
hilarious all of those stories and more
on the bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com